welcome back we're up to Episode seven
and this time we're gonna expand on
functions a little bit and talk about
overloading functions so yep that's what
we're gonna go so sometimes you'll want
functions with the exact same name but
handle different types of variables and
that's where overloading comes in
so whereas this will only handle floats
what happens if we pass in doubles to
this function I don't know let's just
take a look let's so we're gonna change
this number or these variables first
number second number two doubles and it
tries to pass instead of floats and I
gotta go to my folder here and you code
there we go we'll go ahead and compile
it like this and we'll see what happens
it gets ultra confused and doesn't seem
to like it so whereas these errors are a
little confusing just cannot bind non
const l value reference of type float
reference to our value type of float not
a very clear message there but basically
what's going on is I'm trying to pass in
a double where it's looking for a float
reference as you might remember for from
I think the second tutorial doubles are
eight bytes wide and floats are four
bytes wide so it's not gonna fit as a
reference so what we need to do is we
may need to make a second version of
this exact same function that handles
the double version of it and this is
what's called overloading because if you
call this exact punishment with floats
it uses this one if you call this
function with doubles it uses this one
and as you can see visual studio code is
smart enough to see the overloads so
that's what overloading is it's
basically
the same function but with different
variables and based on what variable
you're passing in it chooses which
function then it goes to now if we
compile this it's fine because it
understands it sees the double version
when we call this so it doesn't matter
if these are floats or doubles anymore
we've build it for both and it will use
whichever one it needs and once again
our program works fine
so that is the very basics of function
overloading let me know if you have any
questions thanks for following these
tutorials and watch my videos don't
forget to give this an upvote or a
thumbs up to help let YouTube know that
I'm alive and well or whatever it is
exactly there our algorithm likes and
I'll see you the next one